there's other bizarre things going on
The Daily wires Luke rosiak was on
Tucker Carlson last night and they've
got something weird going down with
JetBlue I it's not related to sex which
is nice but check it out so the majority
of people dying right now of covet have
been vaccinated against covet obviously
didn't work the majority so with that in
mind it's a little weird to learn that
the airline JetBlue is still refusing to
hire people who haven't taken the covet
vaccine even though they're the minority
people who are dying of covet they say
it's part of their commitment to safety
but as it turns out that commitment to
safety does have limits so JetBlue is
hired a violent felon called John
Perry's as a pilot
this man spent nine years in prison for
breaking into the home of a judge he's
on probation until 2044.
yeah John Perry is committed a heinous
crime he broke into the home of a judge
and brutally assaulted the judge's
daughter in the shower with a metal
baton she fled the home bloodied and
naked when he was arrested he was found
wearing a bulletproof vest and in his
car he had knives handcuffs parachute
cord and most disturbingly a shovel so
this is a bad dude now JetBlue forced
all 25
000 of its employees to get vaccinated
last year whether they liked it or not
they won't hire you if you haven't had
the vax but they did hire John Perry's
do you see how whacked out everything is
this guy attacked a judge with a metal
baton and had a shovel a shovel people
you know what you do with the shovel you
dig a hole and then you might throw
somebody in that hole anyway he spent
nine years in jail I don't know more
about the story and maybe the guy has
been completely changed and found the
Lord and all the stuff but he's now a
pilot for JetBlue I like JetBlue I like
those mid seats Daphne we may have to I
have to get on another airline now
because of this I can't have this guy
flying me after all this with the shovel
um but this guy is hired and 25 000
people that work for JetBlue have to be
vaccinated and they will not hire people
if they are not vac so I'm just trying
to show you the asymmetry of craziness
here you could have a perfectly good
pilot great track record never tried to
murder a judge doesn't have a shovel
we're not going to hire him because he's
on vacs we're going to hire this guy but
these sort of inconsistencies I think
people are seeing them everywhere